what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Moren Thompson
and today we have some really big news
for the MCU two new projects two really
big projects right now are currently in
development at Marvel Studios both of
which are sequels and the movies that we
got last for them were pretty
controversial however we do have some
plot details for one of the films and
we'll talk about what the other one
could be about and how they both could
be extremely better than their
predecessor films one is dror strange 3
now we know about this we've heard about
it for a little bit now but we have an
update it has now been listed in
production weekly meaning it is moving
along we'll dive into some details about
this but remember this needs to come out
presumably before Avengers the King
Dynasty at least that's what we've been
told by some insiders and the other
project is Thor 5 now we pretty much
knew that Thor was not done after the
events of Thor love and thunder yes the
movie did receive a lot of criticism and
a lot of people said that they did not
like this movie the same kind of goes
for Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness there are a lot of people out
there who said they didn't like it
however as we've learned there are many
people out there that said that they
have loved the film and actually won
awards as well Fan Awards proving that
fans actually did love the movie but
there of course are groups out there who
hated this movie and a lot of people
really did not like Thor love and
thunder and for those people
unfortunately we have some news about
the director and you might not like this
news but we do also have news about the
villain of Thor 5 Tao titiz opened up a
little bit about it in a new special
book for thor1 Thunder and we'll break
down everything you need to know and if
you want to stay up to date on the MCU
be sure to subscribe and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items as well we pick one winner at
the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item so we do have a
lot of information about Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness including
what the plot is going to be about but
let's first talk about Thor 5 because
according to a reason recent report Tao
atiti is going to be returning to direct
the next Thor film now this may upset
some people because I've heard a lot of
people say the next Thor film needs to
be directed by somebody other than taoa
Titi but before you get super nervous
let's talk about what Chris Hemsworth
has talked about when he was discussing
the next Thor film after Thor love and
thunder Chris himsworth after Thor love
and thunder did say that he would return
for a Thor five however he did say that
the script would have to be different
that the tone would have to be different
and Thor himself would have to be a
completely different Thor than what we
saw in Thor love and thunder so right
away the fans who are worried that this
is just going to be maybe an even more
elevated Thor love and thunder you don't
really have to worry about that in fact
it sounds like we're going to go in a
completely different direction and that
could possibly be a more serious Thor
Thor Ragnarok was an incredible movie
and that movie was a great blend of
comedy and seriousness then Thor love
and thunder came and basically doubled
down on the comedy and most of the
complaints were that it was just too
comedic and not serious enough so if
Chris Hemsworth is talking about taking
Thor the character in a different
direction than what we've seen then that
is going in a different direction than a
comedic and silly Thor and there are
many super serious versions of Thor in
the comics and in fact there are some
really dark Thor stories in the comics
for example Rune King Thor is one of the
strongest Thor that we've ever seen and
he's a very serious character and he's
also extremely powerful he has the power
of the Odin force and he can use Rune
magic so if we were taking Thor into a
different direction this is a direction
I would love to see them push towards I
don't think he could probably become
Rune King Thor in the very next film
just because the character progression
hasn't been there yet to build up to
that however if Chris himsworth isn't
done with Thor and wants to stick around
for a couple of more films this is
definitely something that they could
build up to which I think a lot of fans
would really enjoy seeing now in the
Thor 11 Thunder the official movie
special book Tao wititi has already
talked about the villain of Thor 5 and
he's revealed that the villain is going
to be more powerful than Hela now we are
assuming that Thor 5 is going to come
out before the events of Avengers Secret
Wars so one thing that we're obviously
thinking about is the possibility that
the villain could actually be a variant
of Kang the Conqueror Kang and Thor have
definitely gone head-to-head in Marvel
Comics and right now Thor hasn't really
been involved with any of the events
that are kind of taking place in the MCU
right now yes Thor L and thunder is
seemingly going to have some pretty big
effects for the MCU considering how it
introduced a cosmic entity eternity but
there is going to need to be something
that gets him into the fight something
that pulls him into the specific battle
against King the Conqueror a reason for
him to actually return to Earth so what
would make the most sense continuity
wise is for him to be fighting Kang
maybe not the main Prime King but a
variant of King and this will put King
on his radar and this will make him have
to go back to Earth to consult the new
Avengers team there is also another way
that still could connect to King and
this would follow up the events of the
Marvels we know that in the Marvels in
some way shape or form they are going to
connect everything to King the Conqueror
specifically because his technology the
Bengal that Kamala Khan is wearing and
the other one being worn by darbin is
his technology is King Technology and
the Marvels is going to be a film where
Carol Danvers is going to different
parts of the Galaxy so probably not in
the actual movie but after the movie the
Marvels we could find out that Carol
Danver goes and pays Thor a visit and
says hey there's something going on here
and we're going to need your help that's
another way to directly get Thor
involved in the events of Kang the
Conqueror if Kang is not going to be the
villain of Thor 5 Thor has a lot of
different villains he could go up
against and keep in mind we haven't seen
Beta Ray Bill so hopefully he will show
up at some point in time since we have
already visited his home world in
Avengers endgame and we did see a statue
of him in Thor Ragnarok and of course we
have to consider Hercules in the Thor 11
Thunder post credit scene Hercules was
set up to be the next villain of the
next Thor film however in the comics
Hercules and Thor are friends so I'm
expecting something pretty similar to
happen here I don't think he's going to
go on to become a main villain of the
next Thor film or a main villain of the
MCU I think eventually him and Thor are
going to be buddies perhaps he could
even recruit Hercules into the fight
against King I'm assuming that Thor is
going to basically explain everything
that happened in Thor love and thunder
stating he had no choice he had to kill
Gore before he killed all of the Gods he
was simply trying to save all of the
Gods lives including Hercules and his
father Zeus so I'm assuming once Thor
explains everything and they stop
fighting he's going to eventually come
around and see okay Thor wasn't really
trying to do anything bad he was just
trying to save everybody so I would like
to think that a king variant is going to
be the villain of Thor five and we're
going to have a much more serious Vibe
since Kang is threatening not only
Thor's universe but the entire
Multiverse itself and that is where
Doctor Strange comes in according to
production weekly Doctor Strange is a
Marvel Studios project that is in
production right now now obviously the
strikes are going on so some things are
on hold but it is in production meaning
this is a project that they are trying
to get out pretty quickly and like I
mentioned they most likely want this out
before the King Dynasty that's what
we've heard from insiders now what we
know about this film is of course it's
going to deal with incursions but it's
also going to deal with sort of a
multiversal group who is going to be
responsible for kind of stopping these
incursions and correcting them and
according to Insider Alex P from the
cosmic circus this group is going to be
the black priests a multiversal
organization that Clea is a part of and
they have found that two people are at
the center of all of these incursions
and essentially the Multiverse going
into chaos and these two people are the
reasons that it could ultimately be
destroyed one of those persons is K of
course and the other one is Doctor
Strange himself now John kosinski's Mr
Fantastic of the 838 Universe kind of
talked about this but he didn't go into
a lot of detail he did say though they
have found that the biggest threat to
their universe and the Multiverse is
Doctor Strange now what's interesting is
that at one point in time in Marvel
Comics Doctor Strange is actually the
leader of the black priests so they
could be setting that up for the future
of the MCU as well but right now we are
finding out that these more recent
projects that are going to be coming to
the MCU are really starting to set up
and connect to Avengers the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars now Doctor
Strange 3 is supposedly going to adapt a
Time Runs Out storyline time Runs Out
was a Marvel comic story that led
directly up to Avengers Secret Wars and
what's really interesting is that the
story did not end well they did not keep
the Multiverse from being destroyed a
lot of incursions happened and
essentially what ended up happening is
that many Heroes ended up leaving Earth
before it collided with another Earth
that's where the story ended and they
went directly into Secret Wars from
there so it it might be safe to say
Doctor Strange 3 is not going to end
well he is not going to be able to undo
some incursions that he caused and might
even cause some more incursions but of
course keep in mind that it's not just
him Kang is causing incursions as well
which is another reason why we believe
that Kang or a variant of Kang could be
the main villain of Thor 5 this honestly
just makes a lot of sense and would
really start to tie everything together
through all parts of our universe so
Thor 5 is officially in development it
looks like they kind of started it not
too long after Thor love and thunder Tao
atii seems to be the director again and
of course Chris himsworth is going to be
returning as Thor in which he has said
they will have a very different tone for
Thor so hopefully Thor 5 is going to be
a banger of a movie and connect deeply
into Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars but go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below what would you like to see
from Thor 5 and who would you like the
villain to be leave all your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and of course subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news you can also follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof